[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its hosts and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr
joel wallach
[Music]
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie dr joel walk your host a
veterinarian and physician
and i'm here for kids and baby boomers
and seniors who don't want to die at
75.5 like their parents and grandparents
i'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't be sick and miserable
the last 15 to 20 years of parents and
grandparents we do have lines open give
us a call toll free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two again
that's toll free one triple eight three
seven nine two five five two
okay well things progress
time goes on
and so forth and of course we have these
two new cds i've talked been talking
about for a couple of days um
the
let's see here
the one is called dr wallach's laws of
photosynthetic disruption global warming
it um
shows that the
um
which i say the experts are wrong again
and the experts are wrong about
genetics
and inheritance and dna bad dna causing
all these diseases no just nutritional
deficiencies
okay that's why i was nominated for a
nobel prize that's why i got so many
awards over a period of 25 years because
i've found the cause for instant cure so
many diseases including cystic fibrosis
musculus muscular dystrophy cinnamon
test syndrome diabetes you name it okay
uh walling is always there okay because
i'm looking in the right direction and
all these other people
i'll just give them the benefit of the
doubt and just say they were ignorant
because the only other option is
they had an agenda and maybe they knew
but they didn't want to say because they
wanted to create a dairy herd so they
could milk the dairy herd every day okay
so i have all the evidence that shows
that every time
there was
something terrible happen
on earth
mass stops and extinctions
i mean 25 000 species 25 000 species of
trilobites alone
died during the big five
um mass extinctions
over millions of years
okay
and it goes along with the appearance of
glaciers and moraines
and the dinosaurs lived in different
places they didn't have that problem so
they went on for another 100 million
years
well then finally they said lord look at
all those empty valleys there's nobody
there anymore so they moved into all the
all the animals that died
and they died because
the marines and glaciers were still at
work and of course they didn't have any
oxygen
uh all five
mass
extinctions were caused by hypoxia not
from global warming so all the details
here and dates and times and so forth is
in this book
uh coming up
it'll be up i think by the end of this
year a couple of months
but the cd
covers a big chunk of it a doctor walks
loss of photosynthetic disruption global
warming tells you the actual cause of
the mass extinctions because of the
glaciers i just i've spent
a lot of time a lot of money and a lot
of effort putting that one together then
um
through scott tradus i give a lecture in
the philippines
i don't know
some time ago i think six or nine months
ago i didn't remember anymore
and he he forwarded it to many asian
countries including japan and china and
hong kong
singapore
and so on
and
so what he did was very clever
he had a professional translator
speak
in in mandarin and cantonese and i spoke
and then
i would speak for two or three minutes
and then the translator would translate
what i said into mandarin i would speak
for a couple of minutes and the
translator was speaking mandarin all
this is recorded on this cd
and both of these cds are ready now if
you've ever wanted to have a business
with a
chinatown business you know either the
chinese restaurants chinese acupuncture
schools
acupuncture clinics
stores of all kinds all these small
businesses in chinatown i mean they are
hurting bad
they need an extra income so why not
from youngevity and not only can they
sell
products and help people with their
health and they can save them
financially so this second cd is
available now um manchurian prescription
uh the subtitle is a brainwashing
prescription we're talking about
medical prescriptions and so forth
and
um you know if you want to really find
out um who dr walk is get a hold of the
book epigenetics because i'm considered
one of the two founding fathers of that
science that replaced genetics there are
no jaguar transfer diseases there are no
transmitter birth defects
and they did such a good job
the editors did such a good job putting
together
my bio with all the awards i've gotten
it's like crazy
okay so many pages
um of five or six pages of just my
awards and so forth because i've
discovered the causes and that's why you
don't hear about city rebels anymore
that's why i don't hear about monstrous
family they fired jerry lewis because he
believed me and he took
a bunch of
charts of kids we had reversed musculin
and the doctors signed off and said we
don't know why but they don't have much
system where he took it to the
westchester association they fired jerry
lewis and shut down the telethon after
he had earned them two billion dollars
or maybe more
to
um uh you know help kids with most
physically okay they fired jerry lewis
and shut down the teletub because
they didn't want to believe that it was
not genetic and just simple nutritional
deficiencies or they already knew it and
they didn't want anybody else to know it
so they could keep milking the dairy
herd okay who knows we may have to find
out on a lie detector test
then
let's see here i'm going to go to some
of that stuff
and
go to
oh they did find out um and they
reported today what killed this uh young
gal
uh gabby from
okay gabby
pettit okay and they got half the army
and half of everybody else out in the
world looking for the guy they think who
strangled her who killed her but they
released today that she had been
strangled to death and you know what
clues they have i don't know maybe she
had a handful of his hair and
if she was dying she grabbed his hair
and got a handful of this here i don't
know that i'm just wondering how they
can pick him out because maybe she's
sitting and sleeping in the car and
somebody came and choked her to death
to get her money and food and rape her
and all that kind of stuff so we'll find
out why they picked him and again she
may have had a handful of his hair in
her hand back after these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs radio network with your
host dr joel wallick you'd like to talk
to dr wallach call between noon and 1
pacific at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevities beyond tangy
tangerine a blend of plant derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat or yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and it's
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild
youngevities beyond tangy tangerine is
available in one pound canisters and
also in 30 count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product and don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity
hello judy divilbus here if i could only
afford to get one product out of
everything that product would be the
ultimate classic it has the vitamins the
minerals the bioflavonoids it even has
grape seed extract the one product that
would give you just about everything
under the sun you would need for a
perfect nutritional program would be the
ultimate classic by the way people that
are on the go it's very very hard to
take the liquids with them when they go
on their trip to get their supplements
in every day well you know something you
can use the ultimate daily tablets and
the mineral capsules when i'm going on a
trip if i have enough room i just take
the two bottles with me if not just use
a little baggie and take a couple of
daily doses with you it's very simple
it's very easy there's no mess no fuss
no refrigeration just take your capsules
take your tablets and your finish for
the day to order these products call
your local youngevity distributor today
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallace
here for young jody nice life crusade we
do have lines open give us call toll
free 128 379-2552
and again you know i want to remind
everybody that um you know we're still
in this pandemic it's slowed down a
little bit but don't forget that the
vaccines do not kill the viruses they
only alert your body to the bad dna and
rna so you can send your troops your
marines and
and the um navy seals
to
kill and eat the viruses and so forth uh
which of course we're talking about
white blood cells and antibodies and red
blood cells and platelets and all that
kind of stuff
and so you need to have that in good
health so you need to stay away from the
wheat broth around those all the bad
things that kill your intestines so you
can maximize absorption and nutrients
because nutrients are what the
bone marrow needs to make white blood
cells and antibodies and red blood cells
and platelets
and if you're a person who has to go to
the doctor once a month for a
b12 shot in an iron shot because you're
chronically anemic and bleeding under
your skin and bruising on your skin all
kind of stuff you're at high risk okay
because your immune system isn't working
because you're eating gluten and not
supplementing um
just the
um in these days
remember the vaccines are not enough in
the early days vaccines in most cases
were enough because we had wood stoves
we're putting all those minerals from
the wood ashes into our gardens into our
food
and so we're getting those minerals well
once we went to electricity there was no
more wood ashes to put in our food and
so vaccinations became less
effective less efficient because we
weren't getting the nutrition and so
you're responsible for the remission for
the nutrition now i want you to get a
hold of the book hell's kitchen it tells
you everything from
three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th 1882 on pearl street new
york city and the bluff overlooking
the
construction of brooklyn bridge
and that's because
um within 10 12 15 years later 20 years
later all these new diseases showed up
which doctors believed because it was
darling at the time were genetic
but really there were just nutritional
deficiencies that they'd never seen
before and they blamed it on genetics
and so they said well we can treat the
symptoms but we don't know how to
prevent it or reverse it because it's
genetic
well you know
well it's not none of these diseases are
that they see a genetic are i'll say
that again none of the diseases doctors
are genetic are genetic another diseases
doctors here autoimmune are not
autoimmune they're just simple
nutritional deficiencies so you've got
to get rid of gluten no wheat bread
right notice no sugar no carbohydrate
drinks
including the diet ones
because they neutralize stomach acid and
then don't forget the book hell's
kitchen it kind of lays it out for you
step by step by step by step so even a
six-year-old can understand what's going
on here
and then i want you to understand
that the uh recognition that the oldest
people that live the oldest the the
oldest centenarians
are in
hanza
okay they're in hanza
it's a small place between pakistan and
china near the gilgit glacier
and
their average lifespan's 120 but they
have people who live be 160 165 and so
on but 120s are average uh our
average is 75 it used to be 79 we've
lost four years we're now leaving 80
years on the table
because the human life expectancy is 155
and so
you know i need you to really really pay
attention here
and
get a hold of you can get a hold of that
basic family of books let's play doctor
let's be herbal doctor passport chroma
therapy it's all in your head
and
don't forget
again
the hell's kitchen i'd throw in i'd get
the book immortality
and what's going to happen when this new
book comes out it's going to be the new
book is going to be
um book number one there'll be
four other books in there
one is going to be immortality another
one's going to be epigenetics the other
one's going to be
hell's kitchen the other ones would be
dr while cooking about the bad foods and
so those five books are going to consist
of the new book well i'm not going to
reprint all those new all those original
books we're just going to make them
available discounted price when you buy
them with the new book
and so forth but if you already have
them start going through them
or you'll be ahead of the thing this
book is going to be a five book series
of five book study
and so if you don't have any of them and
you buy them all at once you'll get a
nice big discount if you buy them one at
a time you'll have to pay the regular
price
and so i urge you to pay attention to
this because you'll save a lot of time
and money and
avoid an enormous amount of unnecessary
misery now
again
today's numbers forty five million three
hundred twenty seven thousand five
hundred twenty five as of this morning
infections seven hundred thirty four
thousand eight hundred one dead we
subtract our 675 thousand dead in 1918
1919 during spanish flu
that means
that means that we have um
let's see here
591 thousand eight hundred and one yeah
actually i said that wow
we actually have sixty thousand
more infections and they had more only
eighteen months into this we had sixty
thousand more infections than they had
in the spanish flu wow
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs radio network with your
host dr joel wallach if you'd like to
talk to dr wallach call toll-free
888-379-2500
[Music]
the antioxidants found in many fruits
and vegetables are known to help support
and promote good health research has
also shown that dark chocolate once
known as the food of the gods is rich in
healthy nutrients in fact dark chocolate
is higher in antioxidant content than
any other food youngevity has combined a
proprietary blend of velvety rich dark
chocolate with whole fruit pulp and
whole fruit juice extracts from
mangosteen goji or wolfberry acai berry
and cherry along with vitamins and
minerals producing a smooth rich
delectable concentrate called coconutty
it tastes so great i sometimes drink it
right out of the bottle or pour it over
ice cream coconity is highly
bioavailable meaning your body will
absorb and make use of all of these
healthy nutrients if you'd like to learn
more about nutritional supplementation
call your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities hey if you're
like me your life is hectic you don't
know where you're gonna be next between
kids and family and in-laws and work and
traffic and everything else that's
driving me crazy right now my life is
insane i bet your life's insane as well
when do we have time to get every single
nutrient we need to be healthy when well
i've got a tip for you take a product
called pollen burst it's so simple even
i can do it all you have to do is open
the package pour it in water mix it up
and bam you're ready to go it tastes
great it's not one of those medicine
tasting things it tastes great low in
calories helps curb your appetite gives
you natural energy that doesn't let you
crash gives your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and i gotta tell you for a busy
person like me or a busy person like you
we need simple we need good palm versus
your answer taste great try it and
you'll feel better call your local
youngevity distributor to find out how
pollenburst can make you feel better and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick help many
people all the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr wallach is on to something and you
want to try yogevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's
four four 313-444-3 four six three call
right now and leave your name telephone
number or email address and we'll see to
it that the right person contacts you
shortly remember the phone number
313-444-3460
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallace
here for young activity 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two jermaine are you there
i'm here
okay so what's going on in michigan
you're getting people starting to call
you i'm getting more and more people
call me now sort of waking up because
this pandemic has slowed down a little
bit
uh so they're kind of waking up and
participating what's going on in
michigan well the way i see it from what
looking on the internet there's more
people protesting the jab and they're
going quitting their jobs and leaving
you know work and
another pile of them yeah they required
flying in a plane that had been
vaccinated
so it's getting
they can't cover it up anymore it's to
that point where the people are starting
to die
and they they can't cover it up
bad yeah
well and there's a lot of breakthroughs
you know
of the infection people who've been
double vaccinated
like um
brett kavanaugh you know one of the u.s
justices in the
uh supreme court he had a breakthrough
infection he had two vaccinations he
still got the
that's right think about that
it doesn't do anything to prevent it and
so why do they want to force people to
have it that doesn't make sense
well it does make sense when you
understand that the mentality of a
medical doctor is to be a dairy man and
milk the herd
and once you get that in your head
you'll understand why they do what they
do
only dead doctors don't lie
well you hear that yeah i did and i and
i know that but to
give people like for example jan read
that um
in a certain county in florida they're
giving nurses fifteen thousand dollars a
week
to
you know keep giving the vaccinations
and keep their mouth shut about what
it's going to do to you and the doctors
are getting three to four hundred
thousand dollars a month to do the same
thing keep their mouth shut and don't
tell everybody the danger of having that
vaccination
so okay well
you've got to ask yourself why that's a
lot of money
yeah well they're true they're treating
the public as a dairy herd they're
treating the public as a dairy herd
either not difficult
no
it's but it's all coming out i mean the
truth is all coming down that's why
people would rather lose their job than
die from that you know
well here's here's what everybody's
responsibility is they have to take care
of themselves okay whether they decide
to get the vaccination or not
that's not the issue the issue is they
got to get rid of the bad stuff so you
maximize absorption nutrition and to
guarantee optimal nutrition they have to
supplement you can't bet well i'm eating
well when i get people tell me that i
want to go sit down and think when
people say i eat well
well that's meaningless now that was
important
um in the early 1800s when everybody's
putting wood ashes in the gardens and
putting wood ashes in their food they
were getting minerals
if you burned the wood
there were minerals left which you put
in your food you put in the gardens once
they went to electricity they gave up a
source of nutritional minerals that
they'd had for millions of years they
had that that source of nutritional
minerals for millions of years
and they gave it up
okay when they went to electricity and
nobody said ah now wait a minute guys
what are we giving up here
all right there's no more wood ashes so
we need to replace those nutrients but
then nobody said that except me
and
the first time i said it i was working
at yerkes primate center found the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis and
said the same thing they fired me
so they said that what cystic fibrosis
wasn't genetic you don't hear about it
anymore because i got rid of it
back after these messages you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie on
the cbs radio network with your host dr
joel wallach if you'd like to talk to dr
wallach call between noon and 1 pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr wallach is on to something and you
want to try yogevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3460
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313-444-3463
313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
hi this dr joel wallick your host of
dead doctors don't lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse
blood cleanse liver cleanse on the
classical herbal way you want to ask
your youngevity associate for herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that in
your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest i guarantee you it
will give you a cleanse you can control
the dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy nothing
better than a happy colon herbal
rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about on the dead doctors
don't lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
greetings everyone judy davila's here
what do you think of when you hear the
words tangy tangerine well i think of
like a sweet tanging something well what
i'm referring to is the ultimate tangy
tangerine it's a fantastic product it
has everything you need and a great
benefit is it's very very delicious it's
very easy to drink i've suggested it
even to youngsters even children like it
even little guys even little girls they
come right into my office their parents
can't get them to take those chewables
and besides that they're not as good as
tangy tangerine and i give them a little
taste of that and you know something
they're pleased as punch so if it's good
for a child and it tastes delicious why
not you there's no excuse not to take a
vitamin when it tastes as good as that
does so how about it tangy tangerine
should be the answer to all of your
nutritional program problem for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
this is the cbs radio network network
[Music]
we're
back with dead doctors online on the cbs
radio network dr joel wallach here from
giving 95 crusade we do have lines open
give us a call toll free one triple
eight three seven nine two five five two
again that's toll free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if you want to get a hold of those uh
two new cds uh dr walt's law of
photosynthetic disruption and the
um
see here
the manchurian
prescription
and
the brainwashing prescription those two
new cds you can go to www dot drj wallet
www.drjwelick.com and get those
and
i want you to not forget the kids
okay just remember of those 60 000
people we have more dead than they had
during the 1918 1919 spanish flu in two
years in 18 months we have more
uh infections and deaths
okay
60 000 more
deaths than they had in two years we're
only in 18 months
and and so
this is because people aren't paying
attention to details so i want you to
get the kids going on kids toddy and cal
toddy and efas
and don't forget our rebound use our
rebounder sports drink with 100
nutrients instead of you know the colas
and sugary sports drinks and just apple
juice and grape juice and that kind of
stuff
so uses fourth shrink um
and so we have it in
30 sticks you know these little
individual servings in a box we have it
in canisters
um
we're just about ready to get the cans
back but you know don't wait for them i
i have like
five or six boxes of this individual six
i got five or six of the canisters so
i'm always on my on my rebound
and you're going to add 25 to 50 health
beers your kids life get them started
before they're born get them started
before they're born if you have a kid
that's born with some kind of problem
the doctor says genetic or autoimmune
that's because they didn't tell you
they did not tell you to take your
prenatal vitamins you know when you were
a teenager well i'm not planning on
having kids until i'm married okay we'll
start taking the vitamins minerals now
so when you are married 10 years from
now and you're getting pregnant you your
body will be super saturated with the
nutrients which will then give you a
perfect baby as opposed to hoping and
praying that you ate well okay that
that's not going to work kids toddy cal
toddy efas and the rebounds for shrink
okay doug let's go to callers all right
let's head to wisconsin and theresa
you're on with dr wallach
hello teresa you're on the air
oh thank you i have my first uti i drink
a gallon of water a day but my
chiropractor says i have a uti i wonder
if i can take killer biotic to get rid
of uh
the infection okay now okay stop
stop okay how did the chiropractor tell
that you had a uti
uh a urinalysis
okay
all right um do you have a low back do
you have any sciatic or low back stuff
no do you have any knee problems or hip
problems
uh my hips will hurt
but not okay and i'm pretty helpful and
150 pounds at 58 years old
okay comes and goes you have any ring in
your ears any any tinnitus or ringing in
your ears
nope
okay do you have any dizziness or
balance problems
no sir
okay any skin pumps any eggs in the
dermatologist or psoriasis
no sir
any bowel problems general bowel
syndrome celiac disease crohn's disease
diverticulitis
ibs yeah
oh bingo okay
all right well see what's happening here
let me tell you what's happening then
i'll let charmaine give you a program
get your pen and paper ready it's very
simple
um you have
joint which includes your low back
problems and your hips and so forth
and they're squeezing
the
nerves that originate in your low back
and your spinal cord
and go to your pelvis
and you're you're you're having burning
on urination and all this kind of stuff
and so hang on we'll come back and
charmaine will give you a program after
these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs radio network with your
host dr joel wallach if you have a
question for dr wallet call between noon
and 1 pacific at 831-685-1080
toll free 888-379-2552
[Applause]
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr wallach is on to something and you
want to try yogevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313-444-3463
that's 313
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
i am judy de vilvis here i am speaking
to you again i just wanted to tell you
that recently i started drinking the
whey shakes again the chocolate way
shake and you need to remember the whey
shake isn't just for losing weight it's
a fantastic place to get your great
protein and if you're trying to gain
weight you can take it along with your
meals and the best part is if you want
to just have a great protein shake do
like i do put it over ice stir it up and
you can sip on it for 20 minutes to an
hour i do it every single day i
absolutely love it you need to get back
to it too it's really good for you and
it makes not fat but it makes muscle
after you work out and you can also mix
it up in a blender with an egg and you
have the most incredible health protein
shake or mix it with a little water stir
it up and you have a little pudding and
who doesn't like pudding for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the eds radio network dr joel wallach
here for youngevity 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two
and uh doug let's go right back to
teresa okay uh charmaine um theresa is
complaining about a uti uh and one more
question here teresa do you have burning
on urination or do you have cloudy urine
what made
what made you
so it sounds like it it was it is minor
but he thinks that i've had this for one
year
because of a large particle
okay
okay i think you have a back problem and
a hip problem and a squeeze in the
nerves and so do you have burning on
urination or you know what made you look
at uti
i just went in for a routine
chiropractor appointment
uh-huh
so you have no symptoms of uti no
burning on urination you're not peeing
in the bed at night when you're asleep
or anything like that
i do have to get up three times in the
night and i figured that was old age
okay yeah that's polyuria that's a
symptom okay good okay charmaine uh
theresa uh has uh symptoms of um
sciatica you know low back stuff
squeezing the nerves i can't blame it on
a prostate because it's a woman and so
even when doctors blame it on the
prostate it's probably a low back thing
squeezing the nerves and they blame it
on the prostate because they're not
aware
they forgot their anatomy
and physiology and so she's 150 pounds
and she has ibs your old bowel syndrome
which is a what what kind of problem
causes ibs
gluten alert you get an a plus okay so
what would you do for her
with all this
you've got to get on a gluten-free diet
no wheat barley rare oats no fried foods
no burnt animal fat and no oils of any
kind and then at her weight she needs
really two healthy
bone and joint packs
and i would add to it the msm and the
fucoid z and vitamin d3 for absorption
and she could also add the ultimate
daily you know classic
which everybody should take right yeah
right okay ultimate daily classic right
um you have to take three of those twice
at 850 pounds and then
give us a call every couple of weeks
because you're going to get benefit
um
for your back your hips uh your
symptomatology a polyuria which means
you're urinating more times than
with in the normal range usually you
urinate before you go to bed you don't
have to urinate again so you get up if
you get up two three times a night
there's something going on there
okay
uh do you have any pre-diabetes any
sugar problems
no nothing with that but can i'm
supposed to go on an antibiotic but i
don't want to so can i take killer
biotic to get rid of it yes well i don't
think you have an infection but yeah
personally that's your choice but if
you'd rather you could take
you take killer biotic take three of
those twice it has two vowels a month
and also take our colloidal silver for
two droppers full under your tongue 30
minutes for each meal and two droppers
flowing your tongue three minutes for
bedtime and the colloidal silver it's
almost like intravenous it just absorbs
instantly through your oral tissues it
doesn't get down your stomach just goes
absorbs immediately out of your mouth
into your bloodstream and goes
everywhere including to your bladder and
your kidneys and all that kind of stuff
in your brain and so on your lungs and
so on
so
yeah use a killer biotic and use the
um
colloidal silver and then call us every
couple of weeks let us know how things
are going and you can actually you know
go to the pharmacy without a test strip
or excuse me without a prescription and
get test strips for your urine
and uh so they can they'll sell you
those about prescription
so you can tell a lot of what's going on
yourself okay doug let's go to
callers let's head to california and
giovanni you're on with dr wallach
yes sir
yes sir giovanni what's up doctor
my wife has a metastatic
lung cancer stage four
and before she was taking tagrisso for
eight months it worked now it's in the
bone
and now she's doing that uh traditional
chemotherapy ib
okay how much
so i would like to find out if you could
give us uh also america how much does
she weigh
how much does she weigh she weighs 154
okay how old is she
what is her
age she's uh 60 years old
okay and how tall is she
she's about five six
five eight sorry
does she have any other issues any
diabetes high blood pressure arthritis
she has a fatty uh
liver
fatty liver
and
lately that diagnosis is lower low lung
consolidation and left
religion
okay all right charmaine what are we
going to do
for given his lovely wife okay
she's five foot eight um
60 years old 154 pounds
and she got stage four cancer to size a
couple of places gone to other places
she's taking chemotherapy
she does have fatty liver so you need a
big hammer what would you use for her
well i would get around two healthy
brain and heart packs and i would add to
that the
fucoid z for sure
and i would add the ultimate
tangy tangerine
2.0 tablets
and uh
actually i'd give her the oxybody cherry
berry also
okay
and vitamin d3 for absorption
and um
pretty much okay
yeah let's start let's start there let's
start there and so give us a call every
couple of weeks if you would um giovanni
give us a call every time you go to the
doctor and she gets an update so we can
kind of adjust things but this is a
start and you do want to use a heavy
hammer use the two healthy branded heart
packs as char said because there's
things in there that will really support
the immune system and the fucoid z she
wants to have three of those twice as
two bottles a month for capsules if she
prefers the liquid she can get it as a z
radical and take it out to that twice a
day
okay and so do um
um
and if you didn't get it all down you
know doug post this and a couple hours
after
we go off the air you can come back on
and
listen to it again
you can pick it up early in the morning
and so but anyway
it's permanently posted
all right doug let's go to college
dan you're on with dr wallach
well dan you're on the air how can we
help you yes sir hi okay a 59 year old
male uh was real heavy in the cardio
working out and came up with a fib
and the doctors recommended you know the
doing the ablation and
wipes the nurse and she said no
and uh
then got shocked twice and it went in
rhythm but then by the time when you
start running again then it went right
back within a week stop okay stop we
only have
moments here um so um let's see here do
you have any ring in your ears tinnitus
anything like that
yeah
okay uh do you have any balance problems
dizziness
a little bit of high blood pressure
okay any diabetes
no
okay
all right uh charmaine what's going on
here
how much does the first well
it's a it's a mechanical problem it's
really troubling stop
stop stop stop stop no no no stop how
much do you weigh dan
uh 190 five nine
okay yeah start off again charmaine he's
got an osteoporosis of the skull
now you're cooking now you're getting it
but it's still caught the
the
the wiring is being disrupted to his
skull
yes the skull is squeezing the 10th
cranial nerve the vagus nerve that's
what's causing the afib doctors don't
even know this okay
um they don't teach him this in school
okay so and yeah you do not want to get
an ablation i did a lot of autopsies
when people were killed by ablation okay
it's a terrible terrible thing it's very
primitive
it's like you know somebody going into
they have a dental problem and they go
see
a witch doctor and witch doctor cuts
your foot off why'd you cut my foot off
well because
there's um a spirit in your foot causing
your dental problem okay well that's how
crazy it is when they want to give you
an ablation for afib
it's easy to get rid of
and so hang on we're gonna quickly when
we come back get your pen and paper
ready we'll give you
a program after these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs radio network with your
host dr joel wallick if you'd like to
talk to dr wallet call between noon and
1 pacific at 831 685-1080
toll-free 379-2552
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you youngevity's
triple treat chocolate is just that an
antioxidant rich dark chocolate complete
with probiotics to aid in proper
digestion this all natural product
contains no preservatives and for those
with dietary restrictions it's gluten
free dairy free glycemic friendly and
kosher certified not only does triple
treat dark chocolate taste fantastic it
contains super antioxidant blueberries
to absorb free radicals with an auric
value of 16936
per piece triple treat chocolate also
contains a proprietary blend of
probiotics with over 500 million live
healthy bacteria per 8 grams at the time
of manufacture with 80 percent reaching
the intestines which is much more than
most live culture yogurts if you'd like
to learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities in recent years several
studies have discovered the healthy
benefits of drinking coffee youngevity
has now taken it a step further with an
entire product line of healthy coffees
from youngevity's java fit selection of
top shelf gourmet coffees all java fit
coffees are made from 100 percent
premium hand-selected arachaba coffee
beans grown in the finest regions of
latin america all are carefully roasted
creating a delicious rich full-bodied
flavor for an extra boost try java fits
energy extreme 62 a proprietary blend of
nutrients including cambogia green tea
extract an extra shot of caffeine and
niacin designed to support metabolism
and enhance physical performance
available in single cup or single pot
packs contact your local youngevity
distributor to get job evolution coffees
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity
listen to physician and veterinarian dr
joel wallick help many people on the
dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr wallach and
youngevity products have changed their
lives if you're now convinced that dr
wallach is on to something and you want
to try yogevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for you activity 95 crusade and
doug let's go right back to dan quickly
okay ashar said um you want to get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
weep around no sugar no carbon or drinks
you need to take two of the healthy
brain and heart factor month to
photoshopping twice a day get two
bottles a month of the msm so you can
take three with each meal so you can
support and promote means repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a very baby bone
makes including the skull
then i want you to have one ounce twice
a day of our cal toddy it has calcium
vitamin d3 and collagen in it one ounce
twice it has two quarts a month then i
want you to take our ultimate daily
classic tablets take three of those
twice a day that's two bottles a month
that's gonna support and promote healthy
blood pressure healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries even coronary
arteries and kidney arteries and brain
arteries and so forth okay doug let's go
to callers
let's head to boston massachusetts and
david you're on with dr wallach hello
david you're on the air
hi doc
um a couple of things real quick if i
can say it to you uh well we've only got
we only got three or four minutes so you
got to go quick
okay sure um the first issue uh feet
um
how i have had is just information
uh no diagnosis
but i have uh um a cousin his feet are
like
uh i don't know if you want to call
athlete's feet skin is very thick
um
he can't put on white socks when you
take them off the yellow around the toes
is that a
mineral deficiency excess of something
he's eating
okay well he's i'm still not quite clear
does he have an infection between his
toes or does he just have
funny color in his skin
no um if he wears um athletic socks
white thought when you take them off
between your toes is
yellow
it's like uh
oozing from between the toes kind of
thing
okay how old is this guy and how much
does he weigh
oh um
right because he's uh
he's 53
um
tight he's totally me he's like six one
uh guess his weight
uh buck eighty-five
okay all right does he have any other
issues have a pressure diabetes skin
problems
uh he's freckles in his face on is i
wouldn't necessarily call it rosacea but
i i didn't really get a diagnosis from
him but that's an observation that's why
i was called okay okay stop
because we only have seconds now okay
and so basically so you may want to call
again tomorrow but basically
um this guy at 185 pounds needs to have
two healthy branded heart packs for a
month get off all the bad foods a
philadelphia thing twice a day he needs
to take the hair skin and nails take
three of those twice a day he also needs
to use our colloidal silver he can take
it orally you can also put he can use
our hand sanitizer between his toes and
on his feet
um and uh
you can see here fucoid z cancels he can
take three of those twice a day for his
immune system
and let's start there oh it wouldn't
hurt for him at that body weight 185 he
could take two quarts a month of the cal
tidy so you take it out twice a day that
has more calcium it's got more vitamin
d3 it's got collagen in it and so let's
um go with that
uh
if you can try a second one we've only
got
okay um
do you have a kobe pat put together with
uh
um uh colloidal silver and so forth
uh we don't have a kit put together for
for covid okay uh we don't have a kit
but
if you take the 90th century nutrients
get off all the bad food
take the colloidal silver orally and the
hand sanitizer wear a mask distance to
all the things you know to do and
whether or not you get a vaccination
that's up to you okay because the
vaccination itself does not kill the
viruses it just alerts your body to the
bad dna and rna and then you're
responsible for giving everything
uh you need being able to absorb it to
support your immune system because your
immune system the one that has the
marines and the navy seals to come
running in and kill the virus okay the
vaccine does not kill the virus
everybody's misinformed when they think
that the vaccine kills viruses no
no you think about it
brett kavanaugh again
one of our u.s supreme court judges
vaccinations he had you know the double
vaccination thing a month apart
and he had a breakthrough infection well
i guarantee you that tells me that he's
eating gluten and he's not supplementing
with the 90 cents of nutrients and so
um and so many of these 60 000 dead are
people who have breakthrough infections
um why did frank die i mean he had two
vaccinations well because he didn't take
the 90th century nutrients and he didn't
get off the gluten and oatmeal for
breakfast every morning
breakfast of the dead
okay well thank you everybody
um we'll be back again tomorrow thank
you so much sharmaine beautiful job as
usual thank you doug
fantastic job as usual god bless each
and every one of you god bless our
troops god bless our navy seals
and god bless america
[Music]
you